je suis le [__] de président
amenez-moi au Capitole tout de suite
c'est ce que Donald Trump aurait
déclarer le 6 janvier 2021 le jour de
l'attaque l'assaut donné par ses
partisans au Congrès s'est révélations
d'une ancienne collaboratrice de la
Maison Blanche peuvent-elles avoir des
conséquences judiciaires avant d'en
débattre en détail le contenu de cette
audition avec Sandra serkara
Donald Trump était-il au courant que
certains de ses partisans étaient armés
quand il les a appelés à marcher sur le
Capitole le 6 janvier 2021 c'est ce
qu'assure une ancienne collaboratrice de
la Maison Blanche devant la commission
parlementaire elle livre un témoignage
accablant elle évoque une conversation
entre Donald Trump et son chef de
cabinet 4 jours avant l'événement
j'ai entendu le président dire quelque
chose comme je me fiche qu'ils aient des
arbres ils ne sont pas là pour me faire
du mal laisser mes supporters entrer
la jeune femme qui travaillait à côté du
bureau au Val confie également que le
chef de cabinet de l'ancien président
l'avait prévenu que quelque chose de
très grave pourrait advenir finalement
le 6 janvier des centaines de partisans
de Donald Trump force l'entrée du
Capitole pour contester l'élection de
Joe Biden
une marée humaine que Donald Trump
lui-même aurait tenté de rejoindre
le président a indiqué quelque chose
comme je suis le [__] de président
emmenez-moi au Capitole maintenant le
président a tenté d'attraper le volant
son agent de sécurité a saisi son bras
et lui a dit monsieur vous devez retirer
votre main du volant Trump alors
utilisez sa main libre pour se jeter sur
la jambe au niveau des clavicules
Donald Trump qui n'exclut pas de ce
représenter en 2024 ni tout en bloc via
son réseau social qualifiant de tordus
et faux le témoignage au même titre que
l'ensemble des travaux de la commission
parlementaire depuis près d'un an elle a
recueilli plus de 1000 témoignages pour
tenter de faire la lumière sur les
agissements avant pendant et après
l'assaut du Capitole
que risque Donald Trump a pressé
nouvelle révélations voilà le thème de
notre débat avec Patricia lemonnière
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes en reporter
spécialiste des relations
internationales François Durpaire
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue merci d'être
là vous êtes historiens spécialiste des
États-Unis Jean-Bernard Schmitt
bienvenue à vous aussi directeur de
l'école W spécialiste du complotisme et
co-auteur avec Thomas Huchon de anti
fake news c'est publié aux éditions
First on est également en duplex avec
nicole Bacharan politologue spécialiste
de la société américaine bonsoir Nicole
heureux de vous retrouver sur en duplex
pour cette émission et Mathieu
croissanto à mes côtés évidemment
toujours éditorialiste politique alors
il y a d'abord le premier chapitre dans
ce débat les faits ce 6 janvier 2021 on
vient d'entendre le résumé de l'audition
de de Cassidy shinson donc qui était
collaboratrice Donald Trump à la Maison
Blanche entendu au Congrès Patricia
elmonia même si on s'attend presque à
tout de la part de Trump c'est sa rage
pour ne pas dire ça sa folie moi qui me
frappe et vous c'est ce que on découvre
en fait dans dans ces auditions parce
que d'ailleurs les commentateurs le
disent tous on voit à quel point d'abord
l'homme était isolé entouré de quelques
figures qui faisaient pression ou pas
pression il était dans son dans son
délire c'est-à-dire il s'était convaincu
ce qu'il faut dire que ce projet ou pas
d'ailleurs on le verra monte depuis des
mois donc il arrive ce jour-là il est
totalement convaincu il ne pense même
pas qu'il va qu'il va faire une entorse
hyper grave à la à la constitution enfin
à l'Amérique à son peuple et donc il est
convaincu et donc il est isolé et il
faut s'imaginer cet homme coupé du monde
et tout puissant parce que souvenez-vous
ce qu'il a dit il a dit c'est ce jour-là
c'est le plus grand moment le plus grand
mouvement pour rendre à l'Amérique sa
grandeur enfin faut être perdu dans son
dans son monde pour pouvoir prononcer de
tels propos François Durpaire si on
rencontre un peu dans le détail de cette
audition et de ce qu'elle provoque c'est
un petit c'est comme un jeu de de mécano
sur le rôle de Donald Trump et de son
directeur ou chef de cabinet Marc midoz
qu'est-ce que le témoignage de cassidie
hutinson provoque dans la foulée ça peut
forcer Marc Miller à témoigner ou pas
d'ailleurs alors c'est la sixième
audience et c'est vrai que c'est là pour
ceux qui suivent chaque épisode Netflix
ça a commencé comme un teaser on est
enfin on a un épisode qui nous qui nous
qui nous intéresse parce que il y a eu
un teaser spectaculaire et en souvenez
quand même du Watergate où il y avait
pas de teaser à l'époque ça a commencé
lentement 51 jours mais il y avait un
vrai témoin Howard Hunt qui a fait
l'agent du FBI qui a fait complètement
basculer cette affaire vers la démission
Richard Nixon et là ça manquait d'un
grand témoin et ça manquait vraiment
d'une audience décisive là on a eu
vraiment l'impression avec décider une
ginsen qu'on avait cette audience
décisive c'est-à-dire que c'est pas
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on commande pas
un élément on commente plein de choses
elle a dit plein de choses elle a dit
qu'effectivement Donald Trump dit Angers
moi tes portillons parce que c'est ces
gens sont armés mais ils vont pas tirer
sur moi et je veux un maximum de gens
donc c'est quand même déjà assez lourd
parce qu'après ils vont on a
effectivement cet épisode quand qui a
fait un peu toute la journée des
commentateurs sur voilà je suis le
fucking président et je vais dans je
veux aller au capital je veux aller
chauffeur le ramène vers la Maison
Blanche et lui il veut aller au Capitole
voilà est-ce que c'est The Beast ou pas
The Beast parce que vous savez c'est le
surnom de la voiture limousine du
président mais alors si c'est The Beast
apparemment il peut pas passer devant
the beast parce que il y a une
séparation entre la plage arrière et la
place du conducteur mais c'est pas The
Beast c'est c'est une voiture plus
classique des services quand il y a tout
eu et finalement ce qui ce qui est
peut-être le plus intéressant c'est
peut-être ce qu'on a ce qu'on a
peut-être pas ce dont on n'a pas parlé
aujourd'hui c'est notamment lorsqu'elle
lorsqu'elle dit les conseillers
juridiques disent à Donald Trump qu'il y
a un risque pénal qui a une
responsabilité pénale et vous imaginez
bien que les membres de la commission
ils vont se jeter sur ça pour dire ce
sont ces gens là qu'on veut interroger
attention c'est à deux bandes c'est la
Commission et c'est le ministère de la
justice parce que c'est en parallèle que
fait le ministère de la justice c'est un
grand secret que l'on trouve évidemment
un peu plus tard je repose un peu la
même question à nicole Bacharan sur le
directeur de cabinet juste pour bien
comprendre parce que moi j'arrive un peu
voilà j'ai pas regardé toutes les
auditions etc mais est-ce qu'il a
témoigné est-ce qu'il a refusé de donner
des détails qu'est-ce qui peut se passer
avec lui il a refusé de témoigner et
pour l'instant la Commission n'a pas
réussi à le traîner si vous voulez
à l'audience ils sont un certain nombre
parmi les très proches de Donald Trump
avoir refusé de témoigner ils en ont
encore la liberté ça peut ne pas durer
parce qu'effectivement comme le disait
François il y a des implications pénales
fortes au fond je suppose que vous comme
moi nous avons tous regardé ce qui se
passait en direct le 6 janvier 2021 et
il manquait des petits bouts dans le
puzzle qui ont été remplis hier moi je
me souviens que j'étais évidemment
horrifiée par les images de l'émeute
j'avais écouté Donald Trump et pour moi
c'était très clair qu'il appelait ses
partisans à aller assiéger le Capitole
et en disant je vais vous y conduire je
suis désolé avec vous il a dit comme ça
et moi dans ma tête je me suis dit mais
ils seront pas compte jamais le secret
de service son service de protection ne
le laissera faire et c'est effectivement
ce qui s'est produit l'ont empêché de le
faire mais les choses que l'on ne savait
pas c'est que il avait été informé qu'il
y avait des manifestants armés qu'il
avait demandé que l'on retire les donc
les détecteurs de métaux aux approches
de la Maison Blanche pour que ça
manifestation et l'air très nourri et
quand et qu'enfin il avait quasiment
agressé son service de sécurité et dans
le fait de négliger le fait qu'il y
avait qui avait des gens armés de
demander de baisser la sécurité et de
d'avoir le projet d'aller au Capitole en
tant que Président il n'a pas le droit
d'entrer sans être invité c'est un
ensemble de faits qui peuvent le mettre
mais on va en reparler ensemble selon ce
que se fera ministère de la justice sous
le coup d'accusation extrêmement grave
comme sédition et incitation à l'émeute
on y reviendra effectivement je voudrais
vous entendre Jean-Bernard Schmitt parce
que ce jour-là on reste sur cette
journée du 6 janvier pour commencer
ce sont qu'il équanone et ses
complotistes qui forment un peu le gros
des troupes Trump qui sont là oui c'est
ça ce qu'il faut comprendre vous parliez
de délire et vous parlez de de
dénégation totale de de sortie du réel
c'est que le 6 janvier 2021 c'est le
résultat de deux mois de délire total de
alors une campagne de désinformation
hallucinante de dénégation et de de déni
phénoménal du réel en gros Trump je vous
rappelle dit depuis deux mois qu'il n'a
pas perdu les élections il le dit sur
tous les tons il n'a pas perdu on lui a
volé les élections il conteste et non
seulement il y a des contestations sur
le terrain mais il faut s'en souvenir
c'est une contestation permanente sur
les réseaux sociaux sur Internet
courant de déclaration phénoménale en
permanence et donc on arrive à l'acné si
je puis dire de cette période incroyable
d'ébullition sur les réseaux sociaux qui
mobilisent en premier lieu effectivement
une communauté très particulière donc
les fameux qua non si vous voulez on
pourra redire à peu près pour tout le
monde n'est pas au fait de ce que c'est
mais ce que sont les quads mais je
termine là-dessus qui sont les partisans
frénétiques de Donald Trump convaincu
effectivement que l'élection est en
train d'être votée il les a chauffés à
blanc pendant deux mois il les manipule
il les pousse en fait on dit il a allumé
la mèche le le 6 mais en fait il a
allumé une mèche très longue c'était
mèches longues exactement et c'était
méchong la mèche est allumée le 3
novembre et puis l'explosion finale elle
est le 6 janvier entre temps il a
continué de mettre de la poudre mais
enfin la mèche elle est allumée depuis
longtemps alors vous avez commencé à
évoquer mais on va vraiment rentrer dans
dans le détail de ce que risque Donald
Trump que je propose à Quentin calmer de
nous
rejoindre rebonsoir Quentin alors quelle
réponse à cette question que le risque
le risque juridique ou judiciaire de
Donald Trump et une réponse théorique et
une réponse plus politique alors la
commission d'enquête on l'a vu dans le
portage de Sandra sarkara est en train
d'accumuler des témoignages avec ses
1000 auditions qui ont eu lieu également
c'est 140 000 documents qui ont été
récoltés à la fin des travaux elle
pourrait aboutir en fait à voir comme ça
trouver des chefs d'accusation à la fin
de ces travaux même après l'été et
qu'elle pourra transmettre au procureur
général des États-Unis une personnalité
importante on va y revenir et cela
ouvrirait la porte à ce moment-là
effectivement à des poursuites pénales à
l'encontre de l'ancien président
américain ce qui pourrait lui être
reproché c'est le fait de vouloir
modifier le cours d'une élection une
forme de conspiration ça c'est dans un
des articles de l'US code c'est-à-dire
une loi fédérale qui s'applique sur tous
les États-Unis et donc il y a aussi un
deuxième délit d'obstruction à la
cérémonie du 6 janvier qui est également
concernée et tout cela on bien cela
concerne les messages de Donald Trump le
6 janvier ou l'avait dit à ses partisans
oui fight we fight my hell les
enjoignants a marché sur le Capitole
mais le procureur général pourrait
choisir de ne pas le poursuivre voilà il
s'appelle Merry Guerlin d'iOS Tony
general il pourrait décider de
temporiser afin d'éviter tout nouvel
embrasement des supporters de Donald
Trump mais peut-être que d'ici là en
fait la véritable et un véritable but de
la commission d'enquête il sera atteint
parce que ces sessions qu'on a un peu vu
là sur 6 pans en fait elles sont
diffusées sur toutes les chaînes
d'informations à l'exception de la très
droitière Fox News et en fait le public
américain il prend conscience aussi avec
ses grands show à l'américaine comme ça
extrêmement bien mis en scène et bien
que une implication politique de Donald
Trump dans ce qui s'est passé le 6
janvier et cela en fait pourrait être
finalement le plus important
l'impact politique merci beaucoup
Quentin pour tout ces détails avec un
autre élément justement sur cette cette
impact politique on reviendra au risque
judiciaire juste après si vous le voulez
bien ce sondage et BBC News
Ipsos la question Donald Trump doit-il
être poursuivi près de 60% des
Américains répondent oui à cette
question
Patricia lemonnière et est-ce que pour
autant on peut parler d'un retournement
l'opinion américain ou est-ce que c'est
beaucoup trop tôt pour le dire je pense
que c'est encore beaucoup trop tôt parce
que il faut savoir que quand même très
peu de gens très peu de téléspectateurs
regardent ces émissions et c'est pas la
masse des des électeurs c'est je crois
15% des électeurs ou des votants vous le
chiffre mérite d'être affiné donc c'est
quand même très peu de très peu de gens
et si vous voulez il y avait quand même
une tendance dans l'opinion publique en
delà au-delà de ce de ce sondage qui qui
est très récent qui montrait que la une
partie des Américains était prête par
lassitude peut-être à trouver que ma foi
Trump n'était pas aussi responsable qui
ne semblait et que cette tendance avait
augmenté ces derniers mois alors il est
évident
l'audition d'hier à un fait va faire un
choc dans l'Amérique parce que elle a
apporté de nouveaux éléments et
évidemment je crois que ça va jouer
effectivement sur la perception
peut-être que plus américains regardons
mais il faut savoir que la mairie
qu'aujourd'hui est votre expert qui nous
est en duplexe pour elle confirmer et
bien l'Amérique est profondément
fracturée et que en rajouter sur Donald
Trump aussi accentue cette fracture
c'est à dire les plus convaincus
deviennent plus convaincus et en fait
cette commission d'enquête qu'est-ce
qu'elle est là par ses révélations elle
cherche à révéler un Trump à l'Amérique
du milieu à l'Amérique du milieu qui
justement flotte un peu entre ce qu'il a
fait des et c'est cette Amérique là
qu'elle veut capter mais je ne suis pas
sûr qu'elle y arrive aujourd'hui parce
qu'en même temps c'est cette Amérique
cette Amérique de petit blanc de de
classe moyenne et bien c'est cet
Américain là qui se retrouvait aussi
dans les manifestants devant le Capitole
parce que parmi les personnes arrêtées
j'arrêterai là parmi les personnes
arrêtées et bien il y a simplement 10%
de suprémacistes et la majorité fait
partie de ces petits ce qu'on appelle
cette classe moyenne américaine qui a
peur de s'en avenir alors Mathieu
voulait intervenir je veux juste
comprendre dans l'opinion comment on a
l'image de cette société américaine qui
est attachée à la Constitution pour
laquelle c'est un texte sacré attaché à
au respect de l'État de droit voilà et
comment Donald Trump arrive encore à
s'en sortir aux yeux de l'opinion
publique alors qu'il a piétiné violet
l'État de droit et la
constitutionnel on a cette image de
l'Amérique attachée à la Constitution et
justement c'est une image
très intéressant de mettre ta question
en relation avec ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure il y a souvent alors je sais
pas si c'est vous le partagez mais les
spécialistes des sectes disent on ne
rejoint jamais une secte il y a jamais
personne qui vous dit je suis rentré
dans une secte ce soit n'importe
laquelle d'ailleurs
c'est un peu pareil des partisans de
Donald Trump qui est personne à
l'impression d'être dans une
contre-vérité d'être dans une réalité
parallèle et j'ai quand même les
partisans de Donald Trump ont même
supplanté complètement que Hanon alors
on peut aller chercher des petits bouts
déjà il y a des des des tendances ou des
influences etc mais il y a d'abord et il
y a une toujours à l'intérieur d'une
secte il y a toujours une vérité et
cette vérité la constitué en novembre
autour de l'idée que cette élection a
été volée et ça c'est fondamental c'est
le mensonge initial c'est en fait c'est
la mère de tous les problèmes depuis
l'origine vous posiez la question Thomas
de est-il fou on a été nombreux pendant
le mandat de Donald Trump a refusé
d'analyser Donald Trump sous l'angle de
la cicatrie d'ailleurs l'Association
nationale des psychiatres américains
l'ont dit ils ont dit on analyse pas
quelqu'un à distance on ne l'a pas vu on
peut pas etc mais à partir de novembre à
partir de ce moment où
la question se pose parce que tout le
monde lui dit que cette élection a été
c'est ce que montre vous disiez
qu'est-ce que montre c'est c'est c'est
montre que tout le monde presque de sa
famille à ses avocats lui dise de ceux
qui gère le processus électoral et qui
sont pour la plupart des républicains
lui dit cette élection a été perdue et
il continue il creuse il creuse alors là
une question on va pas pouvoir y
répondre nous c'est est-ce qu'il est fou
totalement fou ou est-ce qu'il est
remarquablement doué politiquement et il
se dit qu'il va pouvoir convaincre
est-ce que c'est du cimisme c'est du
cynisme et effectivement deux tiers des
répuls et là aujourd'hui ce qui divise
les républicains c'est pas pro Trump ou
en titre Trump c'est le rapport à la
vérité il y a des républicains qui
disent cette élection a été perdue et
elle a des républicains qui disent cette
élection elle a été gagnée et Joe Biden
est un usurpateur
pour répondre aussi à votre question le
résultat de
la période absolument folle qu'on
évoquait à partir de novembre c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez 60 millions
d'Américains 60 millions d'Américains
qui pensent que Joe Biden est un
imposteur 60 millions 60 millions c'est
faut se rendre compte de cette
proportion phénoménale de la société
américaine qui et là il faut bien le
dire n'a plus l'impression d'être face à
un adversaire politique mais face à un
imposteur un usurpateur un voleur
c'est-à-dire que ce n'est pas une un
camp politique qui s'oppose à un autre
c'est une partie de la population qui
pense que le pouvoir n'est pas légitime
et ça c'est la réussite si je puis dire
de la stratégie de Donald Trump et là où
je vous rejoins c'est que c'est là où la
société est hyper fracturée et je pense
que effectivement toutes ces personnes
là ne voient même pas le problème
constitutionnel pas du tout alors je me
tourne maintenant vers nicole Bacharan
pour rentrer un peu plus dans le détail
sur les les conséquences juridiques ou
judiciaires de voilà de l'audition
d'hier et de ce qui peut se passer dans
les dans les un jour quels peuvent être
les prochaines étapes on parlait avec
Quentin Calmet de se procureur général
mérite Garland c'est c'est lui qui
détient en quelque sorte un peu le
destin judiciaire de Trump entre entre
ses mains est-ce qu'on peut dire la
prochaine étape en effet le procureur
général c'est tout simplement le
ministre de la Justice et c'est donc lui
qui peut décider de d'ouvrir une enquête
ce qu'on appellerait dans ce cas là une
enquête criminelle sur la conduite de
Donald Trump il faut savoir qu'au
ministère de la Justice cela fait 18
mois qu'il conduisent de multiples
enquêtes sur ce qui s'est passé le 6
janvier qui a plus de 800 personnes qui
ont été inculpées plusieurs centaines de
condamnés ce sont généralement les
personnes qui étaient présentes au
Capitole et qui ont été coupable
d'exaction de destruction de matériel
d'agression contre les policiers etc les
enquêtes se poursuivent et on ne sait
pas à l'extérieur du ministère de la
Justice qu'est-ce qui concerne vraiment
don
la vision des uns et des autres de ce
qui s'était passé n'était pas n'était
pas du tout la même mais surtout on a
affaire à des démocrates qui suivent les
règles et qui ont toujours peur qu'on
leur dise oh attention vous êtes en
train de politique et ça va se retourner
contre vous souvenez-vous de Barack
Obama en 2016 au moment des ingérences
russes dans la campagne en faveur de
Donald Trump il n'avait pas voulu le
rendre public regardez la réaction
démocrate face à l'affaire de
l'avortement grande prudence et là ça
compte je crains que ça continue au
ministère de la Justice des gens qui
sont très prudents judiciairement et
politiquement face à un groupe Donald
Trump et ses plus proches qui
honnêtement sont des gangsters qui
n'obéissent pas du tout au même règle
oui mais dans ce que vous dites moi
c'est à partir du moment où c'est le
ministère de la Justice qui lance la
procédure forcément il y a Patricia
Lemonnier alors je vois ça avec mon
regard de de journalistes français mais
il y a un soupçon de peut-être
d'instrumentalisation politique
effectivement outre le fait de la
question politique et pas faire de
Donald Trump un héros il faut savoir
aussi ça ne s'est jamais passé c'est à
dire qu'il y a eu l'affaire du Watergate
mais Nixon a démissionné avant même que
le processus se mette en marche et
souvenez-vous le président qui a pris la
relève la Gracie donc ça ferait une
jurisprudence énorme dans un traumatisme
presque j'ai envie de dire politique
dans l'Amérique donc est-ce que le
ministre de la justice va prendre cette
responsabilité en risquant en plus de
faire Donald Trump un héros moi j'en
suis pas du tout persuadée je pensais
que la Commission fera des des proposera
des poursuites et puis après
mais après il va avoir les élections des
mites termes surtout elle peut sa
commission en tout cas interroger des
gens les contraignants par exemple Marc
midoz il n'est pas allé devant la
commission quand un procureur fédéral
vous demande de venir la marque midose
il pourra pas se défausser il pourra pas
dire non on peut refuser d'aller devant
le Congrès pas devant des procureurs
fédéraux
et donc il pourra pas pour monter à
priori n'importe quoi devant le
évidemment et là pour le coup on peut se
dire que Tinson c'est une manière c'est
un peu un ballon d'essai c'est un petit
peu pour la Commission en fait là ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que la
Commission à travail pour le ministère
de la Justice habituellement c'est
l'inverse on parlait du Watergate
généralement ministère de la justice
enquête et fournit à des commissions là
c'est la Commission qui fournit un
élément énormément d'éléments et là on
voit bien que il s'orientait il
s'oriente vers deux choses d'abord un
chef d'accuration qui est celui
d'obstruction obstruction à un processus
qui est celui de validation des
résultats et puis le deuxième c'est
l'insurrection alors on va être
l'obstruction est plus facile en terme
de charge de preuve et plus facile de
prouver l'obstruction que l'insurrection
parce que l'insurrection une fois qu'on
aura dit que Trump là inspiré à laisser
faire on a été content vous voyez Nixon
c'est pas exactement la même chose Nixon
a donné l'ordre donc là est-ce qu'on
aura la même preuve
qu'il a donné l'ordre pour le moment en
tout cas
sixième audition on n'a pas la preuve
Donald Trump et donner l'ordre de quoi
que ce soit oui mais il y a quand même
vous l'avez rappelé je vois c'est Nicole
Bachard en qui racontait ça tout à
l'heure c'est révélations donc sur le
fait qu'il y a des manifestants
lourdement armés qui arrivent aux abords
du Capitole information transmise à
Donald Trump il aurait répondu pardon
mais c'est des mots de Donald Trump j'en
ai rien à [__] qu'il soit armé ils ne
sont pas là pour me faire du mal Nicole
vacharan c'est quand même une forme de
complicité
passive pour ça comme comme on veut
est-ce qu'il y a on peut rentrer dans le
détail est-ce qu'il y a une immunité de
l'ancien président ou pas dans dans le
système américain
c'est toute la question évidemment les
avocats du président et ce sont toujours
des équipes extrêmement nombreuses et
extrêmement bien
rémunérés vont dire que il était
absolument persuadé que l'élection a été
volée qui cherchait à défendre le droit
et la justice et que toutes ces actions
sont couvertes par le ce qu'on appelle
le privilège de l'exécutif qui est à peu
près l'immunité présidentielle si vous
voulez si la personne concernée n'était
pas un ancien président mais il y aurait
aucun doute il serait déjà en prison
tellement c'est limpide mais avec toutes
les facteurs politiques et judiciaires
qu'on évoque ensemble c'est beaucoup
plus c'est beaucoup plus compliqué mais
le simple fait de dire ok je sais que
ces gens sont armés laissez-les entrer
approcher de la Maison Blanche dans le
cas précis enlevez-moi ces [__] de
détecteur de métaux pour reprendre son
vocabulaire Thomas comment ça s'y
habituer et je vais les conduire
moi-même au Capitole la question des
armes et des dé de métaux honnêtement ça
veut dire que le président d'une
certaine façon trahit ses devoirs
puisque il n'assure pas l'ordre public
la sécurité ce ne sont pas du tout ces
priorités c'est extrêmement grave mais
il s'agit de Donald Trump qui est dans
une position tout à fait particulière
Donald Trump Jean-Bernard Schmidt qui a
contre-atté sur son réseau social
évidemment trusses vérité il fallait
oser l'appeler vérité c'est alors je le
cite c'est tordu et faux tout comme
l'ensemble des travaux de la commission
voici ce que Donald Trump a dit
aujourd'hui petit point d'étape c'est
toujours son unique canal de
communication il y a ça il est meeting
il est toujours interdit sur les ce jour
interdit on sait que au moment où Elon
Musk a racheté en tout cas commencé à
racheter histoire finalement
une des premières inquiétudes polémiques
ou au contraire joie selon le point de
vue que l'on adopte et que l'on a était
dans l'idée que il puisse réintégrer
Donald Trump sur Twitter cela Trump
avait aussi laissé entendre qu'il
voudrait pas y retourner bon après tout
ça démarre pas super bien et ça a du mal
à ça a du mal à démarrer néanmoins
pour rebondir là-dessus et sur le fait
que là on c'est le terme tordu
d'ailleurs c'est un de ces termes
fétiches puisqu'il a beaucoup utilisé
pour critiquer et pour attaquer Hillary
Clinton en 2016 d'ailleurs lors de la
campagne le fait qu'il utilise et qu'on
retrouve son vocabulaire fétiche
me fait penser une chose c'est que comme
disait nicole Bacharan qu'il est
douloureux d'être nuancé dans un monde
ultra polarisé dans un monde qui ne
l'est absolument pas aujourd'hui c'est
le dilemme des démocrates et c'est le
dilemme de toute une partie de la
société américaine qui croit la
Constitution encore d'ailleurs qui
pourrait attendre elle des poursuites ne
serait-ce que parce que ça serait
paramétré de défendre la Constitution
donc c'est le dilemme aussi de de de
démocrate qui doivent se positionner
face à une opinion
pro républicaine qui a les chauffer à
blanc et qui continue à être chauffé à
blanc sur les réseaux sociaux parce que
la mécanique des réseaux sociaux ne
s'est pas arrêtée avec
le bannissement de de Donald Trump les
partisans sont toujours là les réseaux
sont toujours là ça continue ça continue
et la machine et la Sud Est
algorithmique des réseaux sociaux
continue son ouvrage faut pas croire les
fake news sont toujours plus distribués
que les vérités
si ça va six fois plus vite je l'ai
retenu ça va six fois plus vite mais
surtout les fake news mais pas seulement
vous avez cette idée de de silo
d'information dans lesquelles la
contradiction ne rentre pas et l'un des
principaux problèmes de ces de ces
auditions au-delà du fait que
Fox ne les retransmet pas c'est que vous
avez une partie de l'opinion qui est
polarisée de toute façon et qui ne va
même pas recevoir cette information
et ce sont ceux-là qui vont aller
soutenir Donald Trump alors il y a une
question qui moi me passionne aussi
c'est la question du du parti
républicain le ground Party c'est ça
c'est son surnom et on peut dire que le
destin de cette commission d'enquête
dépend aussi du parti républicain et des
résultats résultats des prochaines
élections élections de mi-mandat s'étant
novembre alors des sondages à 5 mois bon
ici en France on est prudents on le sera
aussi mais voilà ce qu'on a trouvé comme
sondage ça date de cette semaine 44,6%
des personnes disent qui vont plutôt
voter républicains et 42,7% pour les
démocrates bref c'est c'est très partagé
Patricia Lemonnier si on se projette
imaginons c'est quand même une vraie
possibilité que les républicains
l'emportent ils l'ont déjà dit que
vont-ils faire des résultats de cette
commission d'enquête ils ont dit qu'il
la considérait comme nul et non advenues
donc l'affaire est pliée est claire mais
elle a cette commission et c'est
recommandations resteront quand même
dans l'opinion publique et participeront
à cette à cette fracture qui qui ne fait
à mon avis que s'élargir aujourd'hui
dans la société américaine et ce qui est
très intéressant c'est quand il y a eu
je pars entrer dans le détail mais il y
a eu des élections si vous voulez des
primaires au sein des parties
républicains pour élire leur
représentants aux fameux élections qui
vont se tenir en novembre et bien il
faut savoir que ceux qui ont émergé et
qui ont été élus en quelque sorte pour
porter les couleurs du fameux parti
républicain du grand rôle parti et bien
50% sont persuadés c'est-à-dire la
moitié plus de la moitié exactement sans
persuader que Donald Trump s'est fait
voler les élections et que Joe Biden est
un usurpateur les gens derrière je vais
juste oui pour apporter du de l'eau à
votre à votre démonstration il y a
l'histoire de de James Vans qui l'a
emporté on est dans l'Ohio il a reçu 13
millions de dollars de la part d'un
milliardaire proche de de Trump c'est un
record de financement pour une primaire
de ce type primaire républicaine pour le
Sénat donc la machine Trump elle est
elle est elle est à l'oeuvre d'une
certaine façon et moi j'ai envie de dire
qu'elle fonctionne mais bien avant les
élections de novembre les élections
présidentielles de novembre 18 mois le
projet de Donald Trump pour se maintenir
au pouvoir date d'avant les élections il
est antérieur et donc je pense que
l'homme est totalement persuadé on ne
peut plus le faire sortir de ce chemin
et avec lui il entraîne une partie je
dis bien une partie des républicains qui
est de plus en plus convaincu fermé avec
les réseaux sociaux parce qu'il faut
savoir que 50% des Américains c'est un
format où pas la télévision sur les
réseaux sociaux donc ils sont tous pris
dans ces dans ce schéma alors il y a une
autre partie des républicains qui
gardent raison mais pour la salle se
taire et est-ce qu'elle est minoritaire
François durpère cette partie est-ce que
Donald Trump est en train alors il
l'avait déjà fait en remportant
l'élection mais de verrouiller
complètement ce parti républicain est-ce
qu'on peut dire alors c'est difficile de
lire les fins de d'avoir une vision
globale les élections primaires c'est
toujours extrêmement délicat ce qu'il
faut relever c'est que un vous avez tout
à fait raison le grand mensonge sur
l'élection il a commencé à l'été
précédent sur la question de vous vous
souvenez Donald Trump et en raison pour
laquelle Twitter a commencé à lui
chercher des poux et il lui a pas
cherché des poux sur autre chose c'était
vraiment sur le processus électoral il a
commencé à dire vous verrez cette
élection sera truquée parce que les
démocrates vont faire voter des gens qui
ne se déplaceront pas etc donc ça
c'était à l'été précédent novembre ce
qu'il faut et deuxième chose qui est
encore tout à fait juste dans ce que
vous avez dit c'est que les républicains
vont pas se contenter de mettre cela de
côté ils en font le moteur de leurs
élections Nevada Texas Michigan
pennsylva dit ce sont des États où les
primaires ont été gagnées par des
candidats à la primaire républicaine qui
défendent cette idée du mensonge je vous
rappelle que parmi ces candidats un
certain nombre seront gouverneurs et
vont donc superviser le processus
électoral de 2024
c'est donc c'est vous êtes en train de
nous décrire un parti républicain qui a
quand même une tradition tellement
ancienne qui est en train de basculer
dans le dans une autre réalité grosso
modo alors il y a quand même des
divisions au sein du parti républicains
vous savez que cette commission seule de
républicains font partie parce que Kevin
McCarty le chef de la minorité
républicaine à la Chambre a refusé que
les républicains prennent parti et Trump
n'a pas été content du tout de cette
attitude il a dit c'est une décision
stupide parce que si on était à
l'intérieur de cette commission par
exemple jinson on aurait très bien pu
imaginer les républicains lui posant des
questions lui apportant la contradiction
dans un processus démocratique tout à
fait normal au sein d'une commission
parlementaire ça n'a pas été le cas et
ça a été le choix de Kevin McCarthy
choix qui est démonté voilà Donald Trump
et pas du tout satisfait je vais poser
une question à un peu provocatrice
nicole Bacharan qui va certainement
faire réagir voilà voilà des électeurs
républicains ici en France ou aux
États-Unis mais ils nous regardent pas
trop aux Etats-Unis je crois mais
redevenir redevenons sérieux est-ce que
ce parti est perdu pour la démocratie
il y a un fort risque il y a un fort
risque je pense que la question telle
que vous la formulez et tout à fait
juste ce mot ce parti progressivement à
virer de plus en plus à droite on
s'empara notamment des questions
religieuses on le voit avec la question
de l'avortement en virant vers quelque
chose qui ressemble à une poussée pour
faire des Etats-Unis une théocratie pour
que les règles morales privées que les
églises n'arrivent pas à imposer soit
imposées par l'État et ce parti-là a été
a vu son sauvetage si vous voulez dans
dans Donald Trump donc là ce que vous
parlez des primaires et vous avez
totalement raison qui sont pas très
rassurantes pour la démocratie
américaine et en fait les électeurs pro
Trump anti-avortement
pro-arme vivent un triomphe à l'heure
actuelle alors la journée d'hier pour
Trump a pas été mais les arrêts de la
Cour suprême sur l'avortement et sur le
port d'armes sont un triomphe pour ce
mouvement ce sont les mêmes électeurs et
ils sont chauffés à blanc ils
s'inscrivent sur les listes électorales
il vote beaucoup plus que d'autres
électeurs plus ou moins nuancés qui sont
fatigués qui en ont assez de Washington
qui pensent à d'autres sujets comme par
exemple l'inflation ou le ou le ou le
prix de l'essence et il y a il y a
vraiment un mouvement très fort
minoritaire mais très fort dans
les soutiens républicains qui tirent ce
parti vers l'extrême droite vers même
chose le j'ose le terme après tout on a
parlé aujourd'hui vers quelque chose qui
ressemble à un néo fascisme et Patricia
parlé tout à l'heure de la constitution
de cette image d'unité autour de la
Constitution et en effet ça n'est qu'une
image chacun dit bah la Constitution
elle dit en gros elle dit ce que je veux
et on le voit bien avec le sujet de
fortement protégé par les le droit à la
vie privée dans les constitutions pas du
tout disent les les juges actuels donc
ce parti républicain il peut mourir mais
pour l'instant on en est très loin ça
reste le parti de Donald Trump
survivra à Trump d'une certaine façon
qu'on assiste à une vraie dérive
idéologique tu partirais républicain
très intéressante parce que dans les
élections primaires pour le coup on a
même eu des tentatives d'autonomisation
de candidats j'allais dire trumpiste non
Trump prise pour faire simple des
candidats Maga vous savez mec américain
got again c'est devenu la grande secte
dont on parlait tout à l'heure mec
américain certains candidats se sont dit
mais nous on y va on a une idée on est
porteur d'une idée si Trump nous
soutient tant mieux si nous soutient pas
c'est suffisamment puissant et fort pour
parler donc Trump a déjà survécu à Trump
aujourd'hui maintenant après les les
républicains ont vu quand même que la
polarisation négative avait fonctionné
contre certes ils ont réussi à mobiliser
plus de 70 millions d'Américains mais 80
millions d'Américains se sont mobilisés
contre ce que décrit Nicole donc on peut
tout à fait imaginer qu'une partie des
républicains se disent on n'ira pas à la
primaire avec Donald Trump on va choisir
une voix qui nous permet de gagner les
prochaines élections c'est le mot
important nous permet de gagner des
prochaines élections je crois qu'il y a
la deuxième la deuxième frange au sein
du parti républicain et dans l'attente
enfin l'attend elle attend de voir
justement comment les électeurs la
sensibilité électorale va jouer un
dernier élément et on va écouter Donald
Trump vous l'évoquez nicole Bacharan sur
la décision de la la Cour suprême
concernant
l'avortement il relit ça à son propre
pouvoir évidemment écoutons
j'ai promis de nommer des juges et des
magistrats qui défendront le sens
original de la Constitution et qui
interpréteront honnêtement et fidèlement
la loi telle qu'elle est écrite
nous avons fait confirmer près de 300
juges fédéraux et trois grands juges de
la Cour suprême pour faire exactement
cela
nicole Bacharan je vais vous laisser le
mot de la conclusion sur ce thème il
faut peut-être appeler l'influence des
des juges de la Cour suprême mais aussi
de ces juges fédéraux dans
l'interprétation de la loi si vous dit
tout à l'heure la Constitution chacun
peut lui faire dire un peu ce qu'il veut
mais il y a un vrai impact sur la vie
quotidienne des Américains on l'a vu de
des américaines avec l'addition de la
Cour suprême
ah oui c'est absolument dramatique on
vient d'entendre Donald Trump on peut
dire que sur ce point il a réellement
tenu parole et il a fidélisé autour de
lui notamment les évangéliques les
catholiques les plus conservateurs tous
ceux qui sont en fait des
fondamentalistes religieux qui
maintenant ont le pouvoir à la Cour
suprême et dans une des juges Clarence
Thomas a écrit au sujet de l'avortement
nous n'avons pas du tout à tenir compte
de l'opinion publique ce qui est
totalement faux il y a beaucoup de
décisions notamment sur l'esclavage sur
la ségrégation même dans certains cas
sur la peine de mort ne plus exécutées
par exemple des gens mineurs au moment
de au moment des crimes tout cela tenait
compte de l'évolution de la société on a
des idéologues au pouvoir à la Cour
suprême avec une influence énorme et un
risque de Sécession légale aux
États-Unis puisque désormais vous avez
des États dans les lois
longtemps nous positions frontale avec
les lois d'autres États comment est-ce
que ça peut se régler c'est un
casse-tête inimaginable il n'y a pas de
comment dire il y a pas de voix
constitutionnelle juridique politique
pour résoudre ce problème là-dessus
merci beaucoup merci à tous Jean-Bernard
Smith je rappelle le titre du livre que
vous avez écrit avec Thomas Huchon anti
fake news et ses publié aux éditions
First merci encore à tous d'avoir
participé à ce des